[Musique]
et voilà bonsoir à toutes et à tous sur
ce stream dans lequel on va parler de
sciences sociales et on va lire ensemble
un article de sciences sociales alors
aujourd'hui c'est un article qui est
assez intéressant parce que il va nous
parler de l'univers voilà dans lequel
vous baignez peut-être l'univers du
stream du gaming et donc c'est
particulièrement actuel aujourd'hui
comme objet des études alors ces stream
s'adressent à toutes celles et tous ceux
qui souhaitent faire des sciences
sociales soit parce qu'ils apprennent
les sciences sociales élèves de
secondaire ou étudiants ou soit des
personnes qui voudraient continuer à
s'informer continuer à rester au contact
des sciences sociales et donc de
réaliser une sorte de veille par rapport
à ce qui se fait dans les dernières
recherches actuelles en sciences
sociales tout en sachant qu'on ne peut
jamais être totalement exhaustif alors
toutes les informations par rapport à la
chaîne la société qui est aussi une
chaîne twitch un compte facebook un site
web il y a vraiment plein de supports
qu'on a développé mais depuis que la
société existe et bien vous pouvez
retrouver tout ça dans le descriptif de
la vidéo le chat est aussi à votre
disposition et ce qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui soir vous retrouvez
directement la référence dans la
description et donc vous pouvez cliquer
sur le lien vous accéderez directement
au portail Cairn qui vous permettra de
charger de lire en ligne ou de
télécharger en PDF l'article du jour
parce qu'il est gratuit c'est pas
toujours le cas mais celui-ci est en
consultation libre donc profitez-en
donc l'objectif ici c'est vraiment de
comprendre comment
son produit les savoirs les
connaissances en sciences sociales par
rapport à cet objectif alors l'article
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
s'appelle une profession de
l'authenticité on parle des streamers ou
des choux au casters donc la personne
qui vont commenter l'e-sport en ligne
une profession de l'authenticité donc ça
c'est vraiment le concept important ça
va être cette authenticité qu'il faudra
garder si tu veux être un grand streamer
ou une grande streameuse le sous-titre
c'est le régime de proximité des
intermédiaires du jeu vidéo
particulièrement sur twitch et YouTube
article de Samuel coavu qui a écrit pas
mal sur sur le sujet aussi sur les
pratiques culturelles mais je pense que
les thèmes de recherche actuels qu'ils
travaillent sont plutôt liés justement à
médiation numérique et Noémie rock qui a
coécrit donc cet article avec Samuel
coavu
article publié dans la revue réseau en
2020 aux éditions de La Découverte
excellente édition de la découverte
maison d'édition que le que l'on
recommande évidemment et je rappelle que
les revues scientifiques sont des revues
dans lequel on va avoir des comités de
lecture qui vont sélectionner les
articles qui méritent d'être publiés
donc donc c'est ça qui rend l'article
plus fiable que simple article sur un
blog ou sur un site internet d'une
personne qui vous souhaiterait informer
les
internautes de certaines choses là on a
vraiment une double validation donc
c'est ça qui rend ces articles
particulièrement intéressants
voilà alors commençons tout de suite je
ne vais pas vous projeter l'article
comme je vous l'ai dit vous pouvez
directement y accéder via les
informations en description alors la
production médiatique a été fortement
impacté évidemment avec l'arrivée du
numérique et arriver et avec l'arrivée
des plateformes qui vont mettre en
relation des producteurs et des
consommateurs avant globalement tu
écoutais la radio tu regardes la
télévision tu lisais la presse tu lisais
des bouquins mais tout ça était aux
mains de certaines industries et il
était très difficile d'y accéder en tant
que producteur aujourd'hui tout ça a
volé en éclat et monsieur et madame tout
le monde peut produire des contenus
comme on le fait ici dans le cadre de la
société c'est assez facile
et donc l'audiovisuel est
particulièrement touché depuis la fin
des années 2000 l'écoute de la
télévision baisse dans la jeunesse dans
les jeunes générations au profit
d'internet alors il faut aussi
relativiser ça ce n'est pas que les
jeunes générations ne regardent plus la
télévision mais elles le font nettement
moins et elles vont avoir beaucoup
d'autres modes de consommation de
l'information ou de contenu culturel
tandis que le poids des services de vie
de vidéo en ligne comme YouTube ne cesse
de s'accroître l'industrie du jeu vidéo
a connu à sa marge se bouleversement le
streaming les vidéos de jeux vidéo
diffusés en direct avec la plateforme
twitch et le développement plus général
des vidéos en ligne sur twitch comme sur
Youtube transforme ce secteur voilà vous
êtes sur Youtube donc je suppose que
vous connaissez YouTube twitch on en
parle plus loin dans l'article mais
c'est une plateforme comme youtube mais
qui va plutôt se concentrer sur de la
vidéo en direct même si on peut regarder
après coup certaines vidéos et aussi qui
va être fort axé sur des contenus de
jeux vidéo parce que historiquement
twitch était un onglet d'une autre
plateforme qui ne traitait que des jeux
vidéo donc aujourd'hui sur twitch on va
retrouver plein de choses différentes
mais historiquement il faut savoir que
c'est très lié aux jeux vidéo
chaque jour 200 millions de visiteurs
uniques regardent des contenus vidéo
ludiques sur Youtube d'après la
plateforme et twitch revendique 1,4
millions de visiteurs uniques chaque
semaine on observe déjà les effets de
ces plateformes sur la production de jeu
ainsi de nombreux jeux intègrent
désormais directement les usages de
fabrication et de diffusion de vidéos
avec des dispositifs comme
l'enregistrement ou le mode spectateur
les impératifs liés à la diffusion vidéo
des parties influences jusqu'aux règles
alors voilà quand j'étais plus jeune il
y a une vingtaine d'années je joue aux
jeux vidéos
en me replongeant dans l'univers twitch
je reviens en contact des jeux vidéo
mais c'est clair qu'il y a eu une grosse
évolution et qu'on n'est pas à une face
à une évolution qui serait à la marge
l'arrivée des plateformes de streaming a
vraiment révolutionné la façon même dont
on joue aux jeux vidéo ça il faut bien
le comprendre si vous n'êtes pas
quelqu'un qui est très proche de cette
culture
les auteurs nous proposent dès lors
leurs questions de recherche sur quel
socle repose la légitimité des streamers
et des streameuses à prescrire des jeux
vidéo et plus généralement à parler de
ces jeux comme ils sont seuls pourquoi
est-ce qu'on les écoute finalement parce
que ils n'ont pas forcément une
compétence qui aurait été validée par
une embauche par une fonction dans une
structure institutionnelle on est sur
autre chose ici et c'est ce qu'on va
explorer dans cet article
leur légitimité repose sur un régime de
proximité là on est face à l'hypothèse
qui va traverser tout l'article et donc
c'est parce qu'ils sont proches qu'on
les considère comme légitime au même
titre que un ami ou une amie qui nous
recommanderait certaines choses on va
lui faire confiance par la proximité
parce qu'on la connaît parce qu'on
qualité on connaissait valeur on
connaissait c'est qualité ses défauts et
donc on va l'écouter pour ça quoi de par
cette proximité c'est en effet parce que
les vidéastes à les vidéastes
apparaissent comme des personnes
ordinaires authentiques et proches que
leurs paroles a de la valeur aux yeux de
leur spectateur comme de leur père ce
régime ne remplace pas l'expertise
l'indépendance et le professionnalisme
qui continue d'être valorisé mais la
proximité constitue la caractéristique
la plus saillante de leur position c'est
vraiment ce qu'on va retrouver chez eux
et qu'on ne va pas retrouver chez
d'autres producteurs de contenus comme
par exemple des revues spécialisées de
jeux vidéo
et donc comment vont-ils travailler
cette proximité nous montrons que le
régime de proximité repose sur la
construction d'une image authentique
c'est-à-dire spontané original et
intègre donc ça c'est vraiment trois
éléments constitutifs la spontanéité
l'originalité et l'intégrité qui doivent
être présents sont des valeurs
finalement que les streamers les
streamers doivent respecter s'ils
veulent assurer leur image authentique
sur laquelle repose la proximité
oui parce que si on se rend compte que
tu as une façade à ce moment là la
proximité va s'effondrer directement et
il y a aussi évidemment tout un lien
interpersonnel avec les spectateurs dont
le maintien engage un travail émotionnel
donc il y a vraiment des affects qui
sont très présents et
qui doivent être maintenues pour que le
lien social puisse exister dans la durée
alors les auteurs nous parlent ici de la
plateformeisation qui est le fait
finalement qu'on va avoir des interfaces
qui vont venir
faciliter fluidifier la rencontre entre
une offre et une demande quelle qu'elle
soit quelle que soit le domaine ou le
marché dans lequel on s'inscrit
le concept de plateformeisation désigne
l'extension croissante d'une forme
organisationnelle la plateforme a de
nouveau secteurs économique une
plateforme est une architecture
programmable conçue pour organiser les
interactions entre
usagers
et de ce fait là il y a une
démocratisation comme on disait en début
de stream de la production culturelle
puisque maintenant tout le monde peut
produire du contenu assez facilement et
du contenu de qualité tant au niveau de
la forme que du fond on voit des
producteurs amateurs des des gens qui
qui produisent tout dans un petit bureau
dans leur appartement qui vont proposer
des contenus très qualitatifs ces
plateformes ont elles aussi élargi les
opportunités en abaissant les barrières
à l'entrée donc le fait que c'est un ça
ait un coup de produire des contenus il
y a 20 30 ans il fallait du matériel
vidéo qui était assez onéreux il fallait
tout un équipement qui aujourd'hui peut
se réduit si on prend le mode de
production le plus sommaire un
smartphone un smartphone suffit déjà à
produire des contenus
donc voilà même 150 euros 200 euros
d'investissement on peut y aller
aisément et faire des choses déjà qui
auront une certaine visibilité
donc ces plateformes ont elles aussi
élargi les opportunités en abaissant les
barrières à l'entrée et de ce fait
accrue l'offre de contenu symétriquement
les conditions de travail et de
rémunération ce sont dégradés donc
évidemment on a aujourd'hui une
profusion d'offres entre ce que nous
propose les médias classiques ce que
nous propose les plateformes de stream
les grandes plateformes comme streaming
ou Amazon Prime et plus voilà toutes les
plateformes participatives ou nous
produisons du contenu nous les petits
producteurs tu as franchement de quoi
faire ça change bien de une unique
chaîne de télévision qui proposait des
programmes sur certains moments de la
journée dans les années 1960 mais on est
d'accord que on a beaucoup de petits
créateurs qui essaient de vivre de leur
activité et qui vont avoir des
conditions de travail très très dégradé
et qui vont devoir faire un petit peu
une course
au petit aux petites tâches pour essayer
de gagner finalement quelque chose qui
ressemble à un au final
de plus les vidéastes sont confrontés à
une concurrence très forte dans laquelle
la différenciation est difficile et les
spectateurs à une offre abondante
présentant de fortes incertitudes quant
à sa qualité le régime de proximité est
adapté à cet environnement les vidéastes
cherchent à produire un lien personnel
fort avec les spectateurs auxquels ces
derniers sont d'autant plus réceptifs
qu'ils tendent à concentrer leur
attention sur un faible nombre de
vidéastes nous avons du temps de cerveau
assez limité et donc il va falloir
sélectionner ce que nous allons regarder
et c'est là que intervient le lien
social si tu as établi un lien social
avec un créateur de contenu tu auras tu
seras plus enclin à aller vers ce
créateur de manière plus durable
ici on va passer vraiment sur le volet
méthodologique alors un article
normalement scientifique ou qui a une
prétention scientifique ou en tout cas
établir des faits de manière rigoureuse
et systématique doit préciser les
recettes qu'il a adoptées les méthodes
qu'il a adopté pour arriver à ce
résultat-là sinon on ne peut pas faire
la reproductivité donc on ne peut pas
reproduire ou vérifier dans d'autres
contextes si on est toujours face au
même aux mêmes éléments aux mêmes
ingrédients notre enquête comporte deux
volets les vidéastes et leur public le
volet producteur apporté sur les
streamers et les shootcasteurs donc
chute-caster c'est les personnes qui
commentent les le eSport nous avons
d'abord produit une cartographie
exploratoire de la scène française des
vidéastes pour cela nous avons établi la
liste de des streamers et chutes-caster
et ont été employés par des WebTV
français soit 180 personnes et étudier
le réseau de recommandations qu'il tissé
entre eux voilà on pourrait dire que là
il y a quand même un parti pris parce
qu'on a quand même des producteurs qui
sont
partie prenante dans le système
institutionnel puisqu'ils ont ils ont
rejoint des plateformes on n'est pas sur
on est plus sur des petits producteurs
indépendants vraiment atomisés sur
l'espace de production et étudier le
réseau de recommandations qu'il tient
entre cela nous a permis de repérer des
communautés fortement structurées par le
type de jeu pratiqué avec des
communautés importantes autour de des
jeux sans trop comme League of Legend et
d'autres plus restreinte autour de jeux
de niche en particulier les jeux
indépendants
nous avons sélectionné dans ce réseau
une quarantaine de personnes en
cherchant un maximiser la diversité en
matière de communauté de popularité des
vidéastes et de genre et les avons
contacté via twitch ou Twitter pour
obtenir 18 entretiens donc faut bien se
dire que en sciences sociales on est
toujours sur des effectifs ou une
observation surtout si on veut faire un
observation plus qualitative qui vont
être assez réduits et qui empêche de
facto une général une généralisation
abusive on ne peut pas retirer des
choses générales d'un si petite
échantillon mais voilà on peut avoir des
principes qui pourront être
vérifiés dans d'autres observations pour
des travaux des recherches futures
ils se sont déroulés durant l'été 2018
majoritairement face à face et parfois à
distance avec le logiciel discord ils
ont duré entre 1h15 et 4h et autour de
deux heures en moyenne d'ailleurs je
vous invite à aller voir dans la
description de la vidéo le lien vers
notre discorde sur lequel on peut
échanger notamment sur des questions de
méthodologie et aussi je tenais à dire
par rapport à ce que je viens de lire
que l'article a été publié en 2020 mais
on voit que l'observation a été réalisée
en 2018 et donc il faut bien aussi
prendre en compte qu'il y a toujours un
décalage entre la réalisation de la
recherche et sa publication et donc
souvent la science en général quelle
qu'elle soit quelle que soit son objet a
toujours un temps de retard sur
l'actualité mais c'est pas le but de
toute façon de faire de l'actualité
du fait de ce mode de sélection nous
enquêter sont des personnes visibles
avec une popularité suffisante pour
avoir été repéré par des acteurs
professionnels et qui tirent un revenu
certains stades de leur activité les
sommes brutes qu'il déclarent
collectivement vont de 200 à 4000 euros
par mois donc on a quand même une
certaine diversité de revenus elles sont
cependant assez concentrés seuls 6
déclarent moins de 1000 euros par mois
dont deux ont moins au moins ont connu
depuis l'entretien une croissance
importante de leur visibilité sur twitch
et un seul départ c'est 3000 euros par
mois la tranche de revenus mensuels
modal est donc de 1000 à 2000 euros ses
revenus sont corrélés à leur popularité
mesurait en nombre d'abonnés ou en
nombre de moyens de spectateurs deux
vidéastes seulement exercent une autre
activité professionnelle en parallèle
donc on est quand même sur un public qui
est assez professionnalisé les
shootcasteurs sont souvent étudiants à
l'université ou dans des écoles de
commerce les streamers exercent quant à
eux souvent à temps plein
ils ont de plus faibles niveaux d'études
dans des formations professionnelles
mais certains font exception comme
quelqu'un qui aurait un Master de
Sciences Sociales
la moitié de nos enquêter habite la
région parisienne les autres de grandes
villes de province sauf un qui vit dans
une capitale européenne donc on a pas de
de streamer ruraux alors encore
faudrait-il qu'il y en ait des streamers
ruraux qui vont avoir une certaine
notoriété et qui vont pouvoir entrer
dans le jeu organisationnel de ces
plateformes parce que on pourra pas tous
ces streamers en fait sont
été recrutés à un certain moment par des
Web TV
tout ça en commun de vouloir travailler
dans le secteur du jeu vidéo depuis
longtemps aucun par contre n'avait de
vocation à devenir streamer ou
shootcaster contrairement à la musique
populaire ou les praticiens commencent
comme fans les streamers interrogènes
regardaient pas twitch avant de devenir
vidéaste alors là il me semble qu'il y a
un petit décalage parce qu'en fait on ne
vise pas la même chose ils étaient quand
même amateurs de l'objet qu'ils vont
streamer le stream n'étant finalement à
mon sens qu'un moyen comme les musiciens
n'ont certainement jamais réalisé
tous leurs propres enregistrement
peut-être donc je trouve qu'il y a un
petit décalage à ce moment là de
l'article de même les shootcasteurs sont
souvent des joueurs compétitifs
prétendant à la professionnalisation en
tant que joueur à qui l'on a proposé de
commencer des compétitions notons
toutefois que dans leur immense majorité
les streamers et shootcaster se sont
orientés vers des cursus de formation
valorisant la parole publique théâtre
journaliste radiophonique marketing
droit ou exercer des nécessitant des
compétences d'éloquence et d'animation
animation radio vente chargées de
mission en relation avant de s'engager
dans ces carrières les entretiens ont
notamment portés sur les trajectoires
professionnelles le contenu de
l'activité les stratégies de visibilité
les relations entre professionnels et
les relations avec les publics en outre
nous avons observé au moins une session
live pour chaque streamer interrogé peut
avant l'entretien et mener une veille
sur twitch et sur les réseaux sociaux
donc là on a vraiment plusieurs outils
d'observation qu'on met en oeuvre les
entretiens mais l'observation aussi sous
forme de veille sous
visionnage aussi des streams et
notamment de ce qui se passe dans les
chats et ça c'est très important parce
que ça va venir vraiment nourrir
l'article tout au long de la lecture
nous mobilisons ponctuellement le
matériel issu de ces de ces observations
dans l'article
[Musique]
des autres méthodes donc on avait un
public très masculin et donc ici ils
essaient vraiment d'aller chercher de
plier leur échantillon pour y faire
rentrer des stimuleuses afin que ça soit
relativement représentatif
les entretiens étaient compensés par un
chèque cadeau c'est une pratique qui est
assez courantes où on participe à des
tombola quand on réalise quand on
participe à une enquête les enquêteurs
résidents à Paris en région parisienne
et dans trois grands agglomérations de
province la plupart sont adultes et ont
entre 20 et 30 ans mais plusieurs sont
plus âgés jusqu'à 45 ans les quelques
données marketing dont nous disposons
sur le public de twitch indique une
concentration de cette pratique chez les
jeunes adultes ce qui correspond à notre
échantillon malgré nos tentatives de
diversification l'échantillon est très
masculin il est cependant varié du point
de vue de la position sociale allant des
classes populaires stabilisées donc
c'est les secrétaires agent de police
donc là on est sur des personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément beaucoup de moyens
mais qui ne sont pas non plus menacés
par une précarité directe ou immédiate
au classe supérieure cadre supérieur ou
privé ingénieur en passant par des
professions intermédiaires variées
techniciens commercial
chacun représentant environ un tiers des
enquêtés de niveau de diplôme allant du
CAP au doctorat les entretiens duraient
entre une et deux heures avec une
moyenne de 1h30 et portée principalement
sur l'inscription de la pratique dans la
vie quotidienne des enquêtés mais
comprenez également de nombreuses
questions vivant visant à déterminer les
critères déterminants les jugements
portés sur les vidéastes alors c'est
intéressant on a lu récemment sur la
chaîne twitch la société un article qui
nous parlait justement des pratiques
culturelles et là on a bien vu que en
fait entre garçons et filles le gap qui
pouvait exister en termes de pratique
des jeux vidéo
est en train de se résorber même si au
niveau des jeux vidéo sur lesquels
l'activité porte vont varier en fonction
du genre
quant à l'âge on a vu aussi que
maintenant la pratique du gaming se
diffuse vraiment dans tous les âges les
gamers il y a 20 ans maintenant sont
devenus des adultes qui continuent pour
la plupart à jouer et les jeunes
continuent à jouer donc ce qui fait que
on a un vieillissement du public
du vidéo gaming
qui se fait et au niveau des catégories
sociales on pourrait penser que voilà
quand on vient d'une classe populaire on
a moins accès au numérique mais ce n'est
ça ne se vérifie pas tout le monde a un
accès au numérique alors peut-être pas
pour faire toujours le même type
d'activité mais en tout cas voilà il y a
pas forcément un gros gap entre
l'origine sociale et la pratique de jeux
vidéo
comme le théorie Richard Peterson la
structure industrielle influe sur la
forme des carrières artistiques lorsque
la production culturelle est intégrée
dans de grandes organisations les
carrières se font plus bureaucratiques
et standardisés donc on doit respecter
un petit peu les canons de l'industrie
dans laquelle on s'investit comme
l'industrie du disque par exemple mais
lorsqu'elle est atomisée comme sur les
plateformes la différenciation par
l'authenticité et primordiale parce
qu'on va avoir beaucoup de petits
producteurs et donc il y a une sorte de
prime à l'authenticité à celui qui
transmet l'image la plus la plus proche
finalement des viewers et des
spectateurs
l'authenticité des vidéastes est ainsi
au principe d'une relation qui se veut
égalitaire même si elle est inégalitaire
on a l'illusion qu'elle est égalitaire
c'est quelqu'un comme nous qui nous
parle par les vidéos par le stream la
communication entre père remplacerait la
hiérarchie traditionnelle entre experts
et public et tout ça se mélange beaucoup
plus comment cette relation se
construit-elle et ça va être tout
l'enjeu de l'article c'est d'essayer de
comprendre ça il y a une sorte de
paradoxe on l'a dit tout à l'heure pour
que ça marche en stream il faut que la
personne qui stream soit authentique ou
apparaissent en tout cas puisque on ne
va jamais vérifier réellement si elle
l'est ou pas mais il faut qu'elle
apparaisse comme authentique
c'est-à-dire qu'elle soit spontanée
originale et intègre on va revenir sur
ces trois points juste après mais
apparaître authentique n'a rien
d'évident et cela nécessite des
compétences relationnelles de
présentation de soi ainsi qu'un travail
de construction de sa personnalité de
son image parfois stratégique et
conscient donc qui n'a rien
d'authentique mais quelqu'un qui serait
authentique et qui va le rester
sera peut-être apparaître comme moi
authentique que quelqu'un qui a une
stratégie de construction de cette
authenticité donc là on est en plein
paradoxe on est en plein axe de tension
et on est toujours sur des objets quand
ils sont traversés comme ça par des
tensions qui deviennent très
intéressants pour les sciences sociales
ce travail est payant les vidéastes
authentiques s'assurent la fidélité de
leur communauté et construisent des
relations de long terme
alors on va passer en vue ces trois
éléments le fait d'être à la fois
spontané originale et intègre et on va
développer chaque élément
manifestation spontanée de la Passion
vous voyez il faut qu'il y ait quelque
chose qui soit naturel spontané pour
être authentique les vidéastes doivent
d'abord montrer
ostensiblement donc de manière très
visible leur passion pour le jeu vidéo
ils doivent être complètement dedans et
là c'est quelqu'un qui nous parle
un spectateur nous dit qui a 41 ans nous
dit c'est ça quelque part qui fait un
bon streamer tu ressens quand il aime
sur le jeu qu'il kiffe tu le sens ou
quand c'est le jeu d'un éditeur ou
d'indestructeur d'un destructeur d'un
constructeur qui l'apprécie voilà il
faut une sorte de spontanéité pour que
ça marche déjà des commentateurs
sportifs dont la qualité mesurée par
l'équilibre dans une compétence
technique spécifique la connaissance du
sport et l'intérêt des commentaires il
faut pas non plus ne professer que des
banalités sinon ce n'est pas très
intéressant mais il faut quand même
qu'il ait une compétence sociale c'est
affiché son enthousiasme pour le jeu en
cours il faut que le mec nous dit un
streamer et de l'humour si le mec n'a
pas d'humour c'est foutu pour un
animateur si le mec est timide c'est
foutu si le mec ne sait pas rebondir n'a
pas de réparti c'est foutu voilà il faut
quand même une certaine faconde une
certaine capacité d'expression pour que
ça devienne intéressant les
commentateurs pourtant voient leur
spontanéité limitée par une injonction
contradictoire qui les pousse aux
professionnels apprendre moins de place
un shootcaster de 27 ans nous dit tu ne
peux pas toujours dire la vérité des
fois tu es là bon on va faire une petite
pause on ne sait pas trop tu ne vas pas
dire bon les gars pause clope ça casse
les couilles on revient dans 20 minutes
tu représentes une marque tu ne peux pas
donc c'est vraiment jongler entre le
côté
authentique mais en même temps en
sachant que si tu es authentique tu
risques de faire un faux pas qui va être
préjudiciable pour la suite de ton
activité
le conflit entre ces deux normes et
l'une des principales sources de
critiques émises par le spectateur parce
que le faux pas le streamer est toujours
observé et toujours menacé de faire un
faux pas d'être soit trop dans
l'authenticité et donc là de casser
certains codes ou alors de tomber dans
une sorte de professionnalisme qui le
sait qu'il éloigne de l'authenticité et
donc les spectateurs attendent au
tournant les streamers ou les collègues
de la qualité des commentateurs parmi
les spectateurs interrogés les amateurs
de compétition de jeux vidéo déplorent
le manque de professionnalisme des
commentateurs français sur une
compétition en Chine les mecs parlaient
de leur repas le soir alors qu'il y
avait des actions en cours dit un
spectateur de ce point de vue le
substrat fondamental de l'attitude
adéquate des commentateurs et le fait de
prendre leur rôle au sérieux ce qui se
traduit à la fois dans leur apparence
leur comportement et leur discours il y
a un savoir être profond
cependant passez ce niveau minimal la
spontanéité et ce qui différencie les
commentateurs ennuyeux de ceux qui sont
appréciés il s'agit alors de trouver un
équilibre entre les deux injonctions de
toute façon l'e-sport s'est fait en
T-shirt sur des chaises de gaming dans
des chambres il faut rester un petit peu
cohérent avec cet univers là aussi dit
nous dit un shooter et donc quand ça
devient trop d'indé quand ça devient
trop professionnel et bien ça peut
mettre en péril vraiment cette image
authentique qui est tellement nécessaire
au streamer pour fidéliser leur public
alors là c'est une grande question
est-ce que les jeux de plat est-ce que
les stream de plateau
ne tue pas cette authenticité moi
personnellement sur sur twitch les
streams de plateau m'ennuie plutôt je
préfère vraiment le côté streamé de
cuisson son appart depuis sa chambre
voilà ça c'est en lien avec cette
authenticité
une fine et les vidéastes apprécié
notamment en stream sont ceux qui
parviennent à convaincre qui sont les
mêmes en vidéo ou chez eux qui a un
raccord entre leurs différentes vies
quelque part cela signifie par exemple
de rester concentré sur le jeu mais
aussi de limiter les réactions exagérées
souvent soupçonnées d'être fines pour
moi nous dit un spectateur un
commentateur intéressant c'est surtout
quelqu'un qui va être naturel le naturel
participe de la construction de
l'authenticité en ce qu'il montre la
proximité des vidéastes au spectateurs
ils apparaissent comme des gens comme
nous entre guillemets les vidéastes
rejoignent ici les animateurs de
télévision quand ils mettent en scène un
petit peu leur quotidien mais là je ne
vois pas trop la référence la rêve qui
est donné ici par les auteurs
deuxième point on a parlé maintenant de
la spontanéité on va parler de
l'originalité super important pour se
démarquer pour paraître authentique il
faut aussi se distinguer
là aussi la comparaison avec les
animateurs de télévision et pertinentes
l'originalité réside dans la capacité à
être synthétisée par un très de
caractère unique qui fait la marque de
fabrique du producteur culturel et le
rang immédiatement reconnaissable il
faut qu'il y ait une vision créative
distinctive et cohérente par exemple
Joueur du Grenier on sait que c'est un
stream qui va être accès ou
historiquement qui est accès sur des
jeux plus anciens du des jeux Vintage si
tu vas sur une chaîne comme patriarcam
tu sais directement tu vas tomber sur
une chaîne féministe ou éco-féministe je
sais pas comment il faut le dire voilà
il y a une sorte d'étiquette qui est
mise quand même sur l'échelle si tu
avais une chaîne trop généraliste de
stream ou même une chaîne Youtube trop
généraliste qui va dans tous les sens on
risque de se perdre alors après il y a
peut-être des chaînes une fois qu'on est
plus renommés qui vont se perdre mais en
tout cas à jusqu'à une certaine échelle
il faut qu'il y ait une originalité et
une cohérence
l'originalité est indissociable du
naturel souvent en effet il s'agit
d'apparaître comme différent de la norme
dominante tout en participant d'une
transgression suffisamment partagée pour
rencontrer un public parce que si tu
fais quelque chose trop de niche bien à
ce moment-là tu ne vas rencontrer aucun
public cela peut signifier par exemple
d'abote d'opté des codes d'une
subculture
et si on nous dit c'est le témoignage
d'une spectatrice de 26 ans qui nous dit
j'avais juste lu l'article sur Trinity
donc je suis allé voir sa chaîne parce
qu'elle streamait des jeux d'horreur et
c'est assez rare les gens qui streament
des jeux de d'horreur et donc j'y suis
allé un peu par curiosité tout ça et
j'ai vachement accroché à son caractère
je trouvais qu'elle était vachement bien
elle écoute du métal elle est tatouée
elle a des piercings elle n'est vraiment
pas dans la représentation elle est
vraiment dans le fait de jouer d'être
vachement naturel et ça j'ai vraiment
trouvé ça cool
à titre d'exemple il y a vous avez le
droit qui est une chaîne Youtube qui a
dépassé les 100 000 abonnés ou c'est
quelqu'un de plus âgé qui va streamer
sur des questions de droit et il a
construit tout un univers comme ça avec
sa pipe avec un petit peu des codes qui
ne sont jamais vus sur Youtube 100%
original et cette chaîne a connu une
explosion de ces vues et de ce nombre
d'abonnés parce que là on avait une
offre totalement originale et c'est
c'était assez raccord avec la
personnalité
de la personne qui stream je connais pas
son nom qui Stream qui fait les vidéos
il y avait une cohérence dans entre
cette image originale mais aussi la vie
de la personne et c'est ça qui est
difficile parce que on a parfois des
vies qui sont assez uniformes ou
standard et il faut essayer de dénicher
l'élément original quand tu veux
streamer pour que ça puisse rencontrer
une communauté et en tout cas être
reconnue comme quelqu'un d'authentique
dernière dimension donc on a parlé on a
parlé de la spontanéité de l'originalité
ici on va parler de l'intégrité qui est
super importante la dernière dimension
centrale de l'authenticité des vidéastes
et leur intégrité paradoxalement ils
doivent conserver une image d'amateur
pour être appréciée il faut faut pas
tomber dans le professionnalisme sinon
tu vas casser ce lien avec ta communauté
l'exigence d'intégrité est ainsi une
exigence de désintéressement par rapport
à l'argent et donc un streamer
ou un shooter qui va faire tout le temps
référence au sub au don ça va être mal
considéré parce que on doit garder cette
image amateur si tu n'es plus un amateur
et un professionnel ce qu'ils sont et là
on a encore un paradoxe on a des
professionnels qui vont essayer d'avoir
une image originale et authentique
d'amateurs alors qu'ils ne le sont pas
et bien tu peux pas le faire parce que
sinon tu n'es plus sur le même pied
d'égalité que tes viewer et c'est ça qui
fait que ça marche c'est parce que il y
a cette proximité qui s'installe
l'exigence du désintéressement condamne
notamment toutes les formes de rappel ou
d'explicitations du caractère mercantile
de l'activité mais il y a d'autres
professions qui sont liées au
désintéressement des métiers liés au
Caire en soi de la personne ou les
activités d'enseignement ça serait je
pense à ces mal vu de parler d'argent et
du fait que le fait de venir en classe
enseigner c'est juste pour refaire
bouillir la marmite et pour avoir de
l'argent
c'est la même chose ça serait assez mal
vu et on apprécierait pas ça
et donc ici c'est très très prégnant
chez les spectateurs interrogés les
injonctions fréquentes à s'abonner à
liker à commenter sont également mal
perçues chez certains youtubeurs c'est
ce que je trouve dommage c'est qu'on
sent bien qu'ils font ça pour gagner
leur vie nous dit un spectateur de 36
ans c'est bien on gagne sa vie comme on
veut mais parfois ça sent un peu trop
qu'il cherche un peu le pouce bleu la
thune donc voilà encore une fois ils
peuvent le faire mais ça doit rester
vraiment très très discret et pas
prendre le dessus
un spectateur de 31 ans nous dit je fais
des vidéos je vivais dans la rue le mec
touche 30 000 euros par mois tous les
deux trois mois dégustation de céréales
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à Carré le pif et
le piface challenge il montre les deux
vidéos sur youtube il s'agit de thèmes à
leur populaire sur la plateforme c'est
nul c'est nul ça c'est juste le truc
pour faire des putaclic voilà quand on a
du placement de produit quand on a des
démarches putaclic ça va être mal
considéré parce qu'on casse encore une
fois cette authenticité et cette
proximité un spectateur nous dit il le
disait lui-même il dit moi je fais ça
pour vivre il n'en sont caché pas en
plus oui mais si je ne fais pas de vidéo
de dégustation je ne peux pas payer mon
loyer tu es une [ __ ] en fait tu es juste
littéralement une [ __ ] si encore tu le
faisais parce que ça te faisait marrer
encore on pourrait se dire un peu à la
limite donc voilà on va être directement
associé à certains stéréotypes
si on est trop explicite dans la
recherche de rémunération de ressources
on voit ici que l'abandon du discours de
la passion de la justification des
intéressés de la pratique constituent le
principal reproche fait au vidéaste le
spectateur interrogé considère par
exemple que le second degré si ça le
fait marrer de faire une démo et tout ça
serait une pratique plus acceptable
parce que du coup il n'y a pas
l'objectif
pécunier mercantile
les vidéastes sont ainsi parfois mal à
l'aise vis-à-vis de l'argent qu'ils
touchent et en particulier de celui qui
provient de dons des spectateurs donc
qui peuvent atteindre des sommes
importantes alors je sais plus sur quel
stream je voyais quelqu'un dans le chat
qui avait offert mais plus de 1000
abonnements donc ça représente 3000
euros de dons qui ont été faits je crois
que c'est sur la le stream gastronogeek
qui avait été fait à la communauté et
donc au vidéaste au final parce que la
communauté c'est vidéaste qui les
touches quand même donc voilà parfois
plusieurs centaines d'euros de la part
d'une seule personne les gens me donnent
me donner en mode cadeau de Noël cadeau
de Noël et j'étais gêné nous dit un
streamer de 23 ans cependant la
monétisation est justifiée par la
demande des spectateurs aussi donc et
encore un paradoxe c'est pas facile
d'être streamer finalement on navigue
entre les paradoxes et entre les
situations critiques je n'ai pas mis
tout de suite le bouton don ça ne me
paraissait pas du tout naturel de dire
donnez-moi de l'argent c'est petit à
petit la demande des viewers
qui disait on ne peut même pas te faire
de don c'est dommage je me dis un
streamer une streameuse pardon de 22 ans
une autre manière de réintégrer la
rémunération dans une identité
caractérisée par le désintéressement
consiste à réinvestir une partie de
l'argent reçu dans la production de
vidéos ou plus souvent dans le matériel
un streamer nous dit il y a toujours une
petite partie que j'essaie de réinvestir
même si pour le moment je n'en vis pas
il y a toujours un petit truc qui repart
pour la commu et donc le fait de
réinvestir et bien c'est pas le streamer
qui va gagner de l'argent pour s'acheter
je sais pas une nouvelle voiture
c'est pour la communauté au final quoi
même si c'est finalement un écran ou une
caméra ça reste pour la communauté
bonsoir
mode
et bien voilà donc l'article est en dans
le description de la vidéo si tu
souhaites le retrouver il est en
consultation libre donc en plus il est
gratuit et pour aller plus loin Samuel
quoi vous
j'ai moins cherché sur Noemie rock parce
que c'était surtout Samuel coavou qui
était cité
dans le discord a fait quand même pas
mal de d'articles dessus il y a un
article que je pourrais mettre aussi
dans le descriptif mais qui n'est pas
encore là pour l'instant du Collège de
France qui parle aussi de tout ça donc
voilà mais ce n'est pas mon analyse
attention je ne fais que lire des
analyses merci pour le commentaire
donc ils insistent enfin sur la modestie
de leur train de vie parce que
finalement ils font aveu de je vais pas
dire de pauvreté mais ils ne vont pas
montrer finalement qu'ils ont des moyens
alors ça dépend un petit peu parce que
il y a des chaînes YouTube par exemple
qui font des vidéos sur le matériel
informatique et là c'est un petit peu en
lien avec la chaîne de montrer du
matériel et donc ont des équipements
parfois c'est assez onéreux mais c'est
voilà ça c'est un domaine un peu plus
particulier je voudrais de la
tranquillité d'esprit moi c'est tout ce
que je veux me dire demain je peux avoir
un pépin je peux arriver à continuer à
survivre c'est tout ce que je veux nous
dire un streamer de 32 ans alors voilà
il y a un développement aussi d'un
habitus qui fait que on va pas tomber
dans
le je montre mes richesses ou je montre
trop mon niveau de vie quoi
on trouve également une manifestation de
cette exigence d'intégrité dans les
jugements que les spectateurs portent
sur les vidéos sponsorisées les
vidéastes sont en effet pour l'industrie
du jeu vidéo des influenceurs à la
manière d'autres secteurs économiques
comme la mode la cuisine ou le
maquillage ils sont à ce titre
sollicités par les éditeurs pour faire
des vidéos sur les leurs jeux pour les
spectateurs
ici on nous dit c'est important de dire
que la vidéo est sponsorisée que la
personne soit justement transparente
là-dessus nous dit un spectateur de 28
ans de fait twitch a introduit en 2014
une étiquette sponsorisée employée pour
marquer les jeux vidéo et les vidéos
faites à la demande des éditeurs là
encore les vidéastes que nous avons
interrogé sont en accord avec le public
c'est toujours dans ce côté je n'aime
pas trop cacher aux gens si à un moment
je fais une paix une vidéo sponsorisée
il le savent nous dit un shootcaster de
27 ans
et donc ils doivent aussi cultiver pour
rester authentique une indépendance par
rapport aux industries qui peuvent les
contacter alors ici c'est intéressant
parce que les auteurs nous introduisent
une nouvelle problématique dans tout ça
pour moi ça mériterait de faire une
recherche séparée et donc c'est un
article qui est aussi riche et fécond
pour avoir des idées de recherche
YouTube et c'est la stigmate de la Eagle
qui constitue un risque permanent la
Eagle c'est voilà la personne qui va se
dévêtir pour attirer un public qui va
montrer ses formes qui va voilà avoir un
comportement assez aguicheur si je puis
dire le terme péjoratif désigne des
femmes accusées d'afficher un intérêt
fin pour les jeux vidéo et d'attirer un
public masculin en mettant en scène un
corps sexualisé
une streameuse nous dit au début je ne
comprenais pas trop cette définition
après j'ai compris que c'était leur
manière de nous traiter de [ __ ] ce
stéréotype conjugue deux transgressions
d'énormes que nous décrivons ici donc
c'est intéressant parce que ici on a un
dysfonctionnement quelque part avec ce
stéréotype qui apparaît et c'est
justement parce qu'il y a transgression
de des règles de proximité d'autanticité
qu'on a développé précédemment d'une
part l'absence de passion authentique et
d'autre part l'intéressement financier
est donc ça c'est deux erreurs voilà qui
vont faire que on va avoir des jugements
très négatifs par rapport aux personnes
qu'on va juger comme Eagle il est très
présent dans les communautés de
spectateurs et de vidéastes y compris
les spectatrices et donc c'est aussi un
stéréotype de genre mais qui est comment
dire
entretenu par
toutes les personnes quel que soit leur
genre du coup
j'avais essayé de regarder en fait il y
avait des filles que je suivais parce
qu'elle faisait du cosplay le cosplay
c'est déguisement personnage de manga ou
de jeux vidéo et qui faisait aussi des
streams et par contre du coup j'avais
commencé à regarder je me suis assez
vite arrêté parce que je trouvais que ce
n'était pas du tout naturel et donc là
on revient sur la spontanéité et
l'authenticité c'était trop je ne sais
pas comment expliquer ça bon voilà je
montre ma poitrine et je joue un peu aux
jeux vidéo et je fais des blagues et
c'était trop caricatural en fait nous
dit une spectatrice de 26 ans
et donc là il y a une inégalité aussi
entre les hommes et les femmes ou les
hommes ne n'ont pas de stéréotypes comme
ça qu'il leur pèse au dessus de leur
tête il y a pas de d'épée de Damoclès
qui peut leur tomber dessus
contrairement aux femmes qui vont être
plus vite stigmatisés par rapport à ce
stéréotype les hommes peuvent être
beaucoup plus faciles et apparaître
comme beaucoup plus facilement naturel
que les femmes en fait c'est ce qui nous
dit plus loin dans l'article mais je
pense que je ne vais pas vous en parler
je n'ai pas surligné ces informations là
c'est pour ça que je vous en parle
maintenant le succès des vidéastes est
lié à leur capacité à apparaître comme
des pères des égaux des ego des amis et
donc c'est ça qui va faire que ils ont
une légitimité c'est la proximité et
donc tout ce qu'on a expliqué
précédemment c'est ce qui permet
justement de construire cette proximité
ce travail émotionnel cependant est
coûteux demande des compétences
spécifiques et peut s'avérer pesant il
présente également certains risques
notamment de trop dévoiler leur intimité
les conduisant tracer des frontières
quand à ce qui peut être montré mais
aussi d'être surexposé aux problèmes de
leur spectateur donc pour moi c'est
aussi une autre problématique qui vient
s'inviter ici dans la fin de l'article
c'est les dérives finalement que l'on
peut constater par rapport à cette
proximité artificielle alors parce
qu'elle est artificielle une proximité
sociale et culturelle et parfois
il les considère même comme des amis
tout en sachant que la relation est
asymétrique on est face à une relation
par associée
mais il y a une homophilie une
homophilie c'est le fait qu'on va aller
voir des streamers qui nous ressemblent
point de vue sociologique et donc c'est
ce qui va renforcer aussi la proximité
un spectateur nous dit moi je me
rappellerai toujours la première fois
que j'ai vu le Joueur du Grenier j'ai eu
l'impression de voir un pote que je vois
tous les jours je les salué il ne me
connaît pas mais moi je le connais parce
que je le regarde on rigole mais on
rigole des mêmes conneries ce sentiment
d'amitié a une implication il conduit à
privilégier dans les choix des vidéastes
regardez les affinités électives liées à
la proximité sociale par un mécanisme
classique d'homophilie
en sociologie on sait très bien que
c'est plutôt qui se ressemble s'assemble
que les opposés s'attirent
on regarde un vidéaste parce que c'est
quelqu'un que je pourrais voir à
l'extérieur avec qui se faire une bouffe
est possible ou parce que c'est le genre
de personne qui serait dans mon cercle
d'un minou d'une spectatrice ces
proximités sociales sont explicitement
décrites par les spectateurs qui
évoquent notamment l'âge finalement je
me rends compte les gens que je regarde
ont tous le même âge mais là j'ai envie
de dire qu'il y a peut-être aussi le
fait que les streamers qui sont les plus
en vue sont tous de la même génération
parce qu'en fait ils arrivent sur le
stream en même temps quand le stream se
développe et puis un effet en fait de
d'écosystème qui était complètement vide
en tout cas ça c'est une hypothèse
personnelle qu'il faudrait vérifier je
vais essayer de vérifier cette année-ci
ils arrivent sur une niche qui est
totalement vide et donc ils prennent la
place et aujourd'hui un nouveau streamer
aurait beaucoup plus de difficultés à
s'installer donc ce qui fait qu'on va
avoir une génération qui va dominer le
stream comme il y a une génération qui
va dominer YouTube en tout cas sur des
thèmes qui sont les mêmes
voilà
[Musique]
de moins authentique du coup
il y a un travail aussi continue qui est
réalisé les vidéastes doivent se
souvenir des noms de leur spectateur
régulier leur adresse et des messages
personnalisés répondre discuté prendre
en compte leurs commentaires et
s'adapter à leur préférence la prise en
compte la communauté est appréciée par
les spectateurs une spectatrice nous dit
en plus elle est vraiment proche de sa
communauté donc des fois c'est juste
elle va parler de plein de trucs de jeux
où elle n'a pas d'idée sur le jeu
qu'elle va streamer elle demande un peu
la vie des gens il lui propose des trucs
ça j'aime bien ça nous dit une
spectatrice de 26 ans et tout à l'heure
je regardais rapidement le stream de
maudit qui stream sur les sciences
sociales et sur aussi des jeux vidéo et
à plusieurs activités en lien avec les
sciences sociales le stream et cet
univers là et au début elle a pourtant
une grande communauté mais elle salue
vraiment quasi individuellement chacune
des personnes qui intervient et j'étais
intervenu sur plusieurs stream avec le
profil de la société et elle s'est
souvenu de choses que j'avais dit
précédemment dans le chat donc c'est
vraiment ce travail de de proximité cet
effort qui est réalisé par les streamers
qui va maintenir évidemment la relation
un streamer sur lequel on arrive dans le
chat et qui ne réagit pas avec le chat
je parle plutôt d'un petit streamer
parce qu'après les streamers atteignent
parfois des tailles au niveau de leur
communauté qui les empêchent d'avoir des
interactions directes mais en tout cas
ceux qui reviennent régulièrement sont
identifiés sont salués par les streamers
qui ont des grosses communautés donc là
on va plus saluer tout le monde on va
saluer et on va apporter de l'attention
aux commentaires des fidèles qui peuvent
être toute façon visible par des des
icônes des émotes
spécifiques et l'information est
directement disponible la première fois
qu'on a follower la chaîne la première
fois que l'on a
cette abonnée à la chaîne donc voilà
tout ça est pris en compte finalement
peut-être de manière
implicite mais pris en compte
les vidéastes emploient ainsi différents
modes d'interaction avec le public la
plupart de ces interactions souvent
suivent des routines fortement normées
donc voilà on a il y a des codes à
respecter au début d'une vidéo en direct
par exemple ils prennent le temps de
saluer nommément les spectateurs
connectés à mesure qu'ils arrivent en
accordant de l'attention à chacun tout
en s'efforçant de faire exister cette
communauté en énumérant ces membres les
habitués se voient ainsi reconnus en
tant que public régulier
un streamer de 32 ans nous dit j'ai
justement mis un point d'honneur à ce
que ça ne soit pas que des pseudos donc
au début de mes lives je dis bonjour à
tout le monde j'essaie de lire parce que
ça me permet de mémoriser les pseudos
mémoriser je ne m'en souviens pas
vraiment mais je sais tiens cette
personne est déjà venue donc il ne
pourrait pas citer les pseudos qui sont
venus mais une fois qu'il revoit le
pseudo avec les commentaires qui se
souviennent qu'il y a eu toute une
historique d'un interaction c'est assez
intéressant
à réfléchir au niveau cognitif
finalement ce type d'interaction c'est
que ça permet de les humaniser sans
forcément les gens ré c'est des êtres
vivants et c'est vrai que sur les chats
le concept de genre disparaît un peu
se rappeler que c'est des êtres vivants
pareil en vrai quand il y a quelqu'un
qui te fait un don il y a quelqu'un qui
se qui s'abonne mais sur twitch c'est
pour de l'argent c'est ouf de te dire
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui tous les mois va
te donner quelques euros parce qu'il a
décidé de t'aider toi mais ne pas tomber
non plus dans le rapport ou justement
c'est trop humain parce que là justement
tu te bouffes toi il faut trouver une
balance qui n'est pas forcément simple
bonsoir cadavre exquis
c'est vraiment très gentil comme message
alors c'est pas du tout un article de
moi c'est un article de Samuel coavu et
de Noémie rock qui a été publié en 2020
dans la revue réseau donc c'est un
article une recherche de sciences
sociales qui a été publié voilà dans une
revue scientifique et donc toutes les
références bibliographiques sont dans le
descriptif
c'est un article en plus qui est gratuit
à la consultation donc profitez-en parce
que c'est pas toujours le cas alors
souvent sur cairn notamment qui est la
plateforme que j'utilise pour trouver
les articles pour les streams les
articles sont payants si ils datent de
moins de 3 ans mais ce qui n'est pas le
cas de celui-ci donc voilà c'est pas du
tout une analyse personnelle je ne sais
que de la vulgariser en ne lisant pas
tout parce que sinon ça serait quand
même pas très pas très sympa de
m'approprier ou de faire une vidéo
finalement pendant tout le travail donc
j'essaye de commenter pour bien
expliquer ce qu'est la démarche des
sciences sociales et expliquer tous les
éléments de cet article pour ceux et
celles qui ne souhaitent pas tout lire
quoi
alors il y a aussi tout un rituel par
rapport au follow et au subscribe qui
sont payants sur
sur twitch si vous n'êtes pas coutumier
de twitch en fait le follow c'est le
fait de s'abonner sur Youtube et le
subscribe c'est la souscription sur sur
Youtube je pense que ça s'appelle comme
ça
chacun de ces événements fait l'objet
d'une parole de reconnaissance et de
remerciement la gratitude dont font
preuve les vidéastes constituent l'un
des mécanismes de personnalisation de la
relation entre et leur spectateurs alors
quand il y a par exemple un subscribe ou
quelqu'un qui renouvelle son abonnement
donc en fait une fois qu'on souscrit un
abonnement l'abonnement
doit être dénoncé pour être suspendu
donc si on souscrit à l'abonnement ben
voilà c'est en continu jusqu'au moment
où on décide de le résilier mais dès
qu'on se connecte lors d'un d'un live à
ce moment là on a l'occasion de notifier
dans le chat le fait qu'on a renouvelé
son abonnement de manière même si c'est
automatique on peut le mentionner
volontairement et là c'est l'occasion de
mettre un petit mot et donc là parfois
quand c'est des personnes qui sont
depuis très longtemps dans les dans les
communautés et bien là le streamer
s'arrête vraiment prend un temps et
donne vraiment toute de l'importance à
la personne qui a renouvelé son
abonnement
et puis ça peut donner aussi des moments
un peu festifs il y a des chaînes dans
lesquelles les alertes donc il y a
quelque chose qui se passe quand il y a
un subscribe un sub à ce moment là
petite danse je veux dire voilà il y a
de la musique qui vient et donc ça fait
un moment un peu festif aussi
oui pas de souci tout est là et puis il
y aura toujours les commentaires les
c'est ça qui est bien sur Youtube par
rapport à twitch c'est que sur Youtube
tout reste disponible et donc vous
pouvez utiliser les commentaires après
pour poser les questions ou pour
commenter l'article s'il y a des choses
que vous aviez trouvé
intéressantes des choses à noter ou des
choses voilà que vous trouvez pas
cohérentes par rapport à ce que vous
pouvez observer au quotidien
elle explique pourquoi don et
abonnements deux pratiques qui peuvent
apparaître étonnantes puisqu'elles se
font sans réel contrepartie l'accès aux
chaînes étant gratuit sont si répandus
et c'est clair que c'est très rare en
tout cas chez nous sur sur Youtube ça
allait peut-être plus aux États-Unis ou
Youtube est beaucoup plus encore
implanté que chez nous
mais sur twitch il y a beaucoup de dons
qui sont faits et c'est assez
impressionnant quand on y va pour la
première fois si vous n'avez jamais été
sur twitch allez-y vous allez voir c'est
assez impressionnant et donc on peut se
poser la question mais pourquoi est-ce
que les gens donnent autant alors
l'abonnement débute à 3 euros mais comme
je le disais tout à l'heure il y a
parfois des personnes qui vont donner
plusieurs abonnements qui vont offrir
des abonnements à la communauté en fait
et donc ils vont qui vont mettre du 20
euros du 30 euros du 50 euros mais de
manière très très courante c'est des
choses qu'on voit c'est pas des
exceptions quoi et donc on peut se poser
la question mais comment ça se fait que
parce que il donne mais le service est
quand même la présence et donc comment
justifier ça et on ne peut le justifier
que justement par l'hypothèse de cet
article qui est c'est parce qu'il y a
proximité parce qu'on est plus que sur
de la relation numérique par association
on est vraiment sur une relation un lien
social très très fort qui s'est installé
de par cette proximité qui est favorisée
qui est permise par l'authenticité dont
on parle depuis le début de la lecture
s'abonner à la chaîne d'un vidéaste
différent de s'abonner à une chaîne de
télévision ou un service Web puisqu’il
ne s'agit pas de souscrire à un service
mais plutôt de soutenir une personne en
particulier personne que l'on connaît et
qui nous connaît par le biais de ce
geste plus généralement les streamers
font participer leur public de deux
manières via le jeu et via la vie de la
chaîne et donc dans le jeu par exemple
il va y avoir des votes qui vont être
organisés dans le chat pour faire
participer à la communauté au jeu
parfois il y a même des mécanismes qui
sont mis en place dans lequel
les viewers les personnes qui regardent
la vidéo vont
s'ils sont nombreux à s'abonner par
exemple vont mettre en difficulté le
streamer parce que le streamer a dit que
voilà si on atteint tel seuil et bien je
vais faire ceci ou je ferai cela dans le
jeu quoi donc voilà il y a de
l'interaction qui se passe aussi dans le
jeu c'est pas simplement regarder
quelqu'un qui joue et qui commente son
jeu et échanger par rapport à ça c'est
aussi parfois être impliqué dans le jeu
ça peut être aussi des choix qui vont
être posés sur les prochains jeux qui
vont être diffusés sur les émissions qui
pourraient regarder et puis surtout il
va y avoir l'imposition ou la
construction d'une culture locale d'une
de référence propre à la communauté et
donc ça va être des rituels qui vont
s'installer un vocabulaire propre
des blagues d'initié des reprises des
choses qui vont être reprises et
diffusées par les spectateurs fidélisés
des codes à adopter et si on débarque
sur un stream dans lequel on n'est pas
habitué on n'est pas coutumier et bien
on va pas comprendre tout ce qui se
passe la première fois parce qu'il y a
vraiment une culture spécifique une
subculture qui va s'installer dans
chaque stream et c'est par cette
subculture que finalement on fidélise et
que la proximité s'installe parce qu'il
y a une complicité énorme qui
il s'installe et qui est entretenu dans
la communauté la création de contenu
graphiques en lien avec des blagues ou
des moments de complicité entre le
streamer et ce spectateurs participent à
la stabilisation d'une histoire entre
les participants du stream un vidéaste
se voit surnommé le roi des papillons
depuis que sa colocataire lui a mis un
autocollant de papillon sur le casque
durant une vidéo en direct la connivence
avec son public autour des papillons
durent depuis lors et largement
entretenu par ses spectateurs les idées
c'est pas moi qui les ai d'abord c'est
les viewers nous dit un shootcaster de
29 ans
outre l'esthétique de la chaîne la
culture locale passe par des attitudes
sur l'une des chaînes observées la
vidéastes que nous avons nous n'avons
pas pu interroger en entretien fonde son
identité sur ses hurlements de rage lors
d'une observation un spectateur néophyte
écrit dans le chat j'ai perdu de
l'audition mdr ce à quoi elle répond
welcome baby c'est la spécialité de la
maison les spectateurs sur le chat se
place en habituer ah ça elle gueule
peut-on lire ce nouvel arrivant reste
sur la chaîne et interagit avec la
vidéastes et les autres spectateurs
toute la soirée un spectateur de la
communauté lui offre même un mois
d'abonnement donc c'est quelqu'un qui va
offrir un participant du chat
apparemment apprécié un abonnement et
j'ai vécu ça sur les le stream de maudit
puisque un frein à main je lui posais
des questions je dis voilà sa première
fois que je viens je pose des questions
dans le chat et quelqu'un dans le chat
me dit tu vas voir là pas ces mots il y
a pas de langue de bois ici et voilà et
donc le chat prend parti va un petit peu
raconter narrer les spécificités la
culture locale du stream et de ce qui se
passe dans le chat
pas de souci ben voilà merci d'être
passé mode et à bientôt voilà c'est ça
va être diffusé sur la chaîne Youtube
donc ça va être dans les vidéos en
direct on pourra consulter le replay ad
vitam eternam donc voilà c'est pour ça
que je fais le stream sur Youtube
indépendamment de twitch c'est comme ça
ici on a vraiment quelque chose de plus
formalisé qui va rester sur la chaîne
voilà merci d'être passé bonne chance
pour demain
j'ai perdu de l'audition un spectateur
de la communauté lui offre même un mois
d'abonnement voilà certains spectateurs
jouent un rôle particulier dans la
construction de la communauté ce que
ceux que les streamers désignent comme
modérateur il s'agit le plus souvent de
membres du public très investis et
fréquentant la chaîne depuis longtemps
cette fonction le plus souvent bénévole
peut être perçu comme une promotion donc
là il y a du capital symbolique aller
chercher aussi et témoigne d'une
familiarité accrue entre les vidéastes
et leur spectateurs les plus investis il
n'est alors pas étonnant de rencontrer
des streamers qui ont tissé des liens
forts avec les modérateurs un vidéaste
interrogé par exemple à rencontrer sa
petite amie parce qu'elle regardait sa
chaîne dont elle est désormais
modératrice une situation que nous avons
retrouvé par plusieurs fois dans nos
observations donc il faut pas prendre
faut pas opposer finalement une
socialisation
numérique du paras social avec
notre vie sociale il n'y a pas une
opposition entre les deux il y a
vraiment un lien entre les deux on est
sur des prolongements plutôt que sur des
oppositions et des cloisonnement me
semble-t-il
lorsque la présence des spectateurs se
fait trop pesante et ça c'est la
dernière problématique qui est abordée
il considère la relation avec les
vidéastes comme symétrique alors qu'elle
est asymétrique et donc les spectateurs
les viewers vont se permettre des choses
avec le vidéaste un shootcasteur nous
dit parce que j'ai ce côté justement
grand frère c'est très con j'ai plein de
gens qui m'ont dit souvent ils viennent
sur le stream en mode ça me fait du bien
d'être sur ton stream parce que j'ai
telle personne de ma famille qui est
décédée parce que je viens d'être
célibataire et il y a des gens qui
viennent en MP mais sache privée en mode
parce que j'ai déjà parlé de suicides de
dépression parce que c'est un truc que
j'ai connu avec une ex copine donc voilà
ils vont être le réceptacle un petit peu
de toutes les mal-être de la misère que
peuvent connaître les personnes qui
viennent visionner et ça peut être un
peu
problématique à la longue pour les
streamers qui ne sont pas ni non pas la
vocation à faire ça c'est pas le rôle
quelque part c'est pas pour ça qu'ils
viennent aussi streamer et ils n'ont pas
non plus les compétences
c'est débordements dans l'interaction
viennent de ce que les vidéastes font
face à une obligation à se dévoiler pour
entretenir à proximité avec leur public
on est obligé en tant que vidéaste en
tout cas on streamer ils sont obligés de
faire de la proximité mais du coup ça a
un coût
et ce coup il est émotionnel dans un
engagement démesuré par rapport à ce qui
est attendu ils doivent en révéler
suffisamment sur leur personnage pour
apparaître comme authentique et ce
personnage bien qu'il soit employé pour
marquer la distance et toujours
fortement inspiré de leur personnalité
réelle se dévoilement pose lui aussi les
problèmes spécifiques liés au maintien
de l'intimité
donc il y a deux problèmes en un il y a
cette intimité qui est dévoilée il y a
aussi cette intimité ce manque
d'intimité de la part des viewers la
caméra est centrale dans le dispositif
de la vidéo en ligne bien qu'il soit
possible de diffuser uniquement le jeu
pratiqué la très grande majorité des
vidéastes sur un pose un encart filmant
leur visage et une partie de leur
environnement domestique la caméra est
explicitement demandée par les
spectateurs et les vidéastes après une
rapidement qu'elle est nécessaire pour
la rentabilité de leur activité
un shootcuteur nous dit au niveau
monétaire par contre les donations les
abonnements on aime beaucoup voir la
réaction d'un streamer
aucun ne dispose de pièces dédiées à
cette activité ce qui est un peu
remarquable parce que en fait ils sont
tous professionnels mais ils n'ont pas
de pièces Haddock de sorte que le espace
personnel est susceptible d'être vu ils
prennent le risque de dévoiler plus ce
qu'il ne voudrait ils sont en
particulier à exposer leur conjoint à la
caméra face à cela certains préfèrent
couper la vidéo au risque de s'alliéner
une partie du public ou modifier son
angle de manière à le resserrer sur leur
seul visage et à maximiser la partie de
l'appartement ou leur conjoint peut
évoluer sans crainte j'ai tourné la cam
de telle sorte à ce qu'elle ce qu'on
voit seulement la fenêtre et l'étendoir
à linge de temps en temps je l'ai mis
comme ça parce que sinon franchement on
voit tout mon appart et on voit ma
copine quand elle passe elle veut pas du
tout qu'on la voit nous dit un streamer
d'autres investissent dans un écran vert
qui leur permet d'incruster leur seul
visage sur la vidéo du jeu vidéo
ses parents ainsi la sphère domestiques
de la sphère publique d'autres enfin
négocient avec leur conjoint des plages
d'occupation de l'espace domestique et
ici on a le témoignage d'un streamer qui
nous dit j'ai négocié pendant très très
longtemps avec ma copine qui était
vraiment contre elle dit que c'est du
voyeurisme parce qu'il faut savoir qu'on
a 32 mètres carrés et que tu vois tout
entends tout donc pour la femme qui
partage ta vie elle a peut-être pas
envie qu'on la voit faire des trucs
derrière il faut que le stream soit
coupé quand elle rentre
et je vous invite à aller voir un stream
comme celui de Samuel Étienne qui est le
présentateur et journaliste sur France 2
mais le présentateur de Questions pour
un champion qui lit des
articles de journaux le matin mais lui
c'est vraiment son appartement parfois
ses enfants arrivent et donc là ils
coupent il a une un écran spécifique un
dessin qui a été fait justement par
quelqu'un de la communauté une petite
animation voilà qui empêche qu'on voit
son fils je pense que c'est son fils
de fait les vidéastes craignent de trop
en dire et cherche à s'imposer un
contrôle sur ce dont il parle en vidéo
c'est à dire que je montre aux gens ce
que je veux de ma vie seulement ils
savent uniquement ce que j'ai envie de
montrer
dès que ça implique d'autres personnes
je fais attention je vais dire voilà il
y a un ami qui m'a prêté tel livre je
trouve ça intéressant je fais gaffe à
garder les contours flous parce que je
sais très bien que des fois quand ça
implique d'autres personnes même
d'autres streamers ils n'ont peut-être
pas forcément envie qu'on parle de ça
donc j'essaie de faire attention par
rapport à ça
j'essaie de ne pas trop mettre ma vie
privée en avant par exemple je ne
répondrai jamais à la question tu es
célibataire ou tu es en couple même si
des fois je sous-entends clairement que
j'ai une sex friend
justement parce que je ne veux pas trop
que les gens se disent que je suis
célibataire pour ne pas qu'il m'envoie
trop de messages c'est vraiment très
difficile de jongler sur le qu'est-ce
que tu partages qu'est-ce que tu ne
partages pas nous dit une streuse de 27
ans
on constate de ce point de vue une
inégalité de genre marqué le danger à
parler de soi et beaucoup plus grand
pour les femmes que pour les hommes de
sorte que ces derniers peuvent être plus
aisément apparaître pardon peuvent
aisément apparaître comme des personnes
ordinaires et proches c'est ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure plutôt dans
le stream et bien voilà on a déjà la
conclusion je ne vais pas tout lire
parce que je pense que l'article était
très très clair et ça je remercie
vraiment les auteurs pour la limpidité
de l'écriture ça fait plaisir de lire un
tel article c'est vraiment c'est pas du
tout rébarbatif et ils nous disent dans
la conclusion notre étude montre ainsi
que la plateformeisation principalement
étudiée pour ses effets sur les
conditions de travail et d'emploi change
la nature et la valeur même des biens et
produits échangés comme uber ou Airbnb
prétendre remplacer un service
standardisé un personnel l'hôtel le taxi
par un service authentique produit par
un autre identifié ou un chauffeur privé
le marché de la vidéo en ligne
une télévision standardisée avec un
spectacle artisanal singulier et proche
des spectateurs et c'est clairement ce
qui est cherché je pense par beaucoup de
personnes qui vont sur twitch c'est
cette authenticité même peut-être aussi
sur Youtube c'est cette proximité avec
des gens comme monsieur et madame tout
le monde des gens comme nous
les streamers tirent ainsi leur valeur
autant de leur spécialisation sur les
jeux vidéo temp peu abordé par les
médias traditionnels que du fait que la
relation quotidienne qu'il propose à
leur spectateur est inédite les effets
de l'organisation en plateforme sur la
création culturelle sont encore peu
étudiées ils ne seront certes pas les
mêmes sur le marché éclaté des vidéos en
ligne que sur celui beaucoup plus
concentré du cinéma et des séries
télévisées mais il mérite qu'on les
questionne que font wattpad à
littérature ou Spotify à la musique
Netflix au cinéma voilà un très bel
article très intéressant où il y a
beaucoup de problématiques et donc je
vous invite à en prendre connaissance
dans son intégralité avec les références
qui sont notées ici dans la description
de la vidéo je vais mettre tout de suite
ici après le stream une autre référence
qui pourrait être intéressante et je
vous invite bien tout simplement à vous
abonner à la société de telle sorte à ce
que vous soyez prévenus des prochains
directe et des prochains live que nous
ferons pour présenter les articles des
sciences sociales et s'il y a un article
dans votre parcours que vous avez lu et
qui est particulièrement intéressant et
que vous souhaitiez qu'il soit partagé
par une lecture comme ça en direct
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir dans
un commentaire ou l'autre et on y
donnera suite voilà je vous remercie
pour votre attention et je vous dis à
très bientôt ah oui on vient de terminer
donc voilà il faudrait que tu regardes
tout en replay Lucien mais tout sera
disponible voilà je viens de terminer la
lecture mais normalement je vais
reproduire
l'exercice le jeudi soir pas dans les
prochaines semaines mais il faudra
regarder un petit peu dans trois
semaines normalement on dira un autre
article le jeudi soir ici sur cette
chaîne ben voilà je vous remercie en
tout cas pour votre intérêt pour